estas fueron las protestas que
desconcertaron al mundo después de tres
años de ansios masivos y pruebas
constantes los ciudadanos frustrados
salieron a la calle en manifestaciones
generalizadas que el país No había visto
en décadas Beijing ha señalado que una
flexibilización amplia de la política
cero covid podría estar en marcha ya que
las ciudades se preparan para suavizar
las restricciones esta decisión fue
recibida con alivio por parte de la
población
creo que la gente se alegra de que se
suavice la política porque reduce el
impacto en la vida de las personas
todos mis amigos piensan que tras la
reapertura Seguiremos necesitando cierta
protección diaria y que deberemos
abastecernos de algunos medicamentos en
casa así si alguien tiene síntomas no
tendrá que ir al hospital
el presidente del Consejo europeo
la cuestión de las protestas a
Beijing si acusó los jóvenes frustrados
de desatar las protestas y sugirió que
ya que la cepa omicron es menos letal
las políticas del país podrían
suavizarse la flexibilización de las
normas contra el covid 19 en algunas
ciudades fue bien acogida por la
Organización Mundial de la Salud
nos complace saber que las autoridades
chinas están Ajustando sus estrategias
actuales y realmente tratan de calibrar
ahora las medidas de control que
necesitan para este virus con las vidas
los sustentos y los Derechos Humanos de
las personas en las comunidades
las nuevas políticas podrían incluir más
vacunaciones pruebas no obligatorias
en lugar de cierres masivos y la
flexibilización de las normas sobre el
transporte público pero por ahora los
residentes aún no han presenciado un
cambio sobre el terreno